>> Okay, so we talked about, you know, HTML
talks, talks about where these different things are on
the page, or actually what's on the page. CSS
is the where and the how does it look?
>> Yeah, pretty much.
>> And the JavaScript just, like, how does this whole thing fit together. How
does, when I click this, what machinery does that enact to make that happen?
>> Right, yeah. So, if you wanted a static page you
could just have the HTML and CSS, and you wouldn't need JavaScript.
>> Like a blog or something?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> But if you actually want to be able to interact
with things. I mean, you can have some interactions with HTML alone.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But if, especially if you want things to, to move without reloading the page.
>> You basically want it.
>> You want to use some JavaScript.
>> All right. And this together, I mean, I've heard the terms, you
know, front end, back end. This is the front end of a webpage.
>> Yeah, so, so this really doesn't really have a back end.
There's no sending information back to a central server or anything like that.
>> Okay.
>> This is all run on the client computer.
>> Okay, which means me if I'm working it.
>> Yeah. So, when, when you load the page all of these all of
these assets get loaded into your browser.
You, you basically download all of these files.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then it just goes on your computer.
>> Okay.
>> There's
>> There's no talking back and fourth. It's all, it's all there.
>> Right.
>> So, good. It's helpful [LAUGH]. I've never had anyone
just to explain this to me before. So, with the index
like HTML. I did have a hard time when I
was, you know, browsing this at first. I don't know
HTML and it was, it was confusing. So, maybe we
can talk a bit about how to, how to read this.
>> Sure.